[Music]
hello
Stephan curry welcome to the GSB thank
you very much it's nice to be here
have you ever played in front of a house
this packed from time to time
82 nights a year plus 60 okay okay so
before we get started we have a few
special guests Dean Levin call it out I
usually a beautiful wife open the front
room yes she is right here also heard
your your mother will be joining us as
well she might be here right now or in
five minutes we were always late to
church - so somebody here eventually
walking in like so she might come in
during this video she's gonna be on the
screen because I'm actually gonna play a
video we got a video
it's a my favorite Steph Curry interview
okay yeah that's cute
[Laughter]
how much do you guys play baseball we
played baseball a lot we were in
Charlotte um played for about four or
five years and never got in the pitching
but played everything else and I liked
it but I was more interested in
basketball at the time so I um it was
more my sport kind of um I had more kind
of better and it wasn't restful and I
wanted to thank some more on it
you know try to make sure for the final
chance we see that shot in action from
early days it's you made a pretty bold
prediction up there I'm curious like can
you can you tell me what I'm gonna be
when I grew up oh man what you what
you're gonna be successful whatever that
is I would take this cherry obviously
doing something race you don't need me
to validate it but not ice crazy my
voice has changed a lot more facial hair
but it's pretty cool I see one Toronto
Raptors Jersey right here in the crowd
which is kind of crazy I saw it when I
came in and back in early 2000s but yeah
bold prediction that it came true yeah
I'm glad I came to you - it's been
wandering watching you but one of my
favorite things about that video is who
you went in that video right it's your
family which has been a constant thing
in your life the entire time so I'm
actually curious like what does family
mean to you and why I mean family is
everything
there's an example from you know the
time I can remember obviously growing up
with the dad that played in the NBA mom
who was an educator who started a
Montessori School they were too busy or
too busy you know individuals that were
trying to raise a family and have
successful careers and the biggest thing
that they taught us was that we always
support each other we always show up
like they are here today and you like
that much thank you thank you and a part
of that was just you know it was about
shared experiences and having each
other's back and and it gives you a
sense of foundation no matter what life
throws at you not everything's you know
winning championships and riding on
parade buses there's obviously ups and
downs to life that we all go through and
without that foundation I don't know
where I would be and even for you know
the 11 years that I've been out here on
the west coast
you know my family has been
you know a unit and we've we've always
you know support each other and you know
that's that's that's the biggest thing
to to who we are as a family and and
I've tried to you know me nyesha are now
trying to establish that with our three
kids and an understanding that that
work-life balance that it's tough at
times but it always gives us the sense
of purpose and foundation that that we
need sure earlier you mentioned that
your favorite job has been a father so
I'm actually curious has fatherhood
taught you anything about yourself that
you didn't previously know oh
I mean patience and really that I don't
take myself ever too seriously in my in
my in my job because it doesn't matter
how I mean points out school or if we
win or lose when I come home I'm dead
and and that's the best thing about
about you know life you walk in the door
and they're running up to you
hugs and kisses and just that energy
that you got a match every day and so
it's it is the best job is the most
rewarding job it's obviously difficult
you know at times were getting
everything that you're balancing but
it's a I'll ever take those moments for
granted and knowing what that experience
and that interaction with my parents
growing up how that shaped and formed my
life me and my wife had the opportunity
with our village around us to do that
three beautiful young minds that
hopefully can grow up into their own so
it's a beautiful thing for sure I have
no doubt they're gonna grow up to do
amazing things you also you said that
y'all walked into church late every
night which brings me to another topic
that I think it's pretty core to who you
are as a person and it's a religion and
in a world where religion can be a hot
topic button you lean into it right so
you know what is faith mean to you and
you know why do you choose to make that
a part of your brand I feel like well
first and foremost is it is Who I am
you say religion it's it's kind of funny
I think in terms of how I've grown up
it's about my relationship you know with
God and and what that means to me and
how that evolves or has evolved over the
course of my life from the time I was in
third grade when I made that decision
for myself to follow Jesus to know where
I had the ability to be on a stage and a
platform every single day to let that
shine through me with how I you know
conduct myself and and where I shine you
know the glory every chance that I get
and so it's always been a part of who I
am I never knew that I'd had the
opportunity to impact you know people
with the skill and the god-given skill
that I've been given you know on the
basketball court and the opportunities
and just right up you know Bible verse
on my shoe and and people be able to
connect with that or you know find that
for themselves that's big and you know
I'm not a guy that's gonna bash people
over head with the Bible but you you
know who I am you know by the way that
playing and where that that inspiration
and that that foundation comes from and
it's just I don't ever consider it a
part of my brand in a sense it's just a
part of me just being Who I am and
letting that live through me it's
amazing so so faith and family are core
to your support system and I imagine it
was pretty critical growing up given
that there was so there's constant
criticism you know major d1 colleges
overlooked you you landed a spot at
Davidson College so I'm curious for to
everyone in the crowd who and some point
in their life will battle rejection
right like what what advice you have I
mean don't ever lose your confidence
it's obviously easier said than done
we all have have dealt with that in some
way shape or form where you set a goal
for yourself and for whatever reason
there are roadblocks you know along the
way the biggest thing that I learned
through my recruiting process and ended
up at Davidson where people were like
where the heck is Davidson College
like they even have a basketball team
why are you going there you're the son
of an NBA player you should be going to
the ACC to this and that and trying to
tell you what your life was supposed to
be like there are no accidents in life
to me and the fact that I got rejected
landed me right where I was supposed to
be and I wouldn't change that for
anything and even though I didn't see it
at the time I walked into that
opportunity and you know kind of the
rest is history with you know the
college turning into the NBA it was a
small liberal arts 1,800 student college
that was 30 minutes from my house and
felt like I was still in high school and
part of it was I got to be around one of
the greatest coaches that is in college
basketball and Bob McKillip who really
in a sense leaned into the person way
more than the basketball player and
created that connection in terms of
building what it you know what a man is
supposed to be on off the court and I've
carried so many lessons from him through
my journey that I'm forever grateful for
for what he saw in me when I didn't even
see it for myself and giving me that
opportunity to kind of just play
basketball and learn on a daily and he
challenged me every single day and so
when I was in high school so yeah can I
play at Virginia Tech can i play it do
kind of play North Carolina wasn't my
journey it wasn't where I supposed to be
and I I was alright with that it's
amazing well I'm glad you went to
Davidson College oh you went there you
blew expectations out of the water your
sophomore year you led Davidson on that
magical run through the NCAA tournament
and in that tournament Stefan curry
became a household name right so I'm
curious how was that transition into the
spotlight
it was weird right so you grew up in
Charlotte and my dad again is played in
the NBA for he played there for ten
years we're 16 year MBA
so everywhere we went in Charlotte he
was a celebrity and it was all about him
right so he was you know there one of
the original Hornets we go to dinner
fans would be running up to him
everywhere and I got to see how gracious
he was with everybody that came up to
him you know talking to the kids that
looked up to him and you know spending a
moment with him understanding how
valuable that interaction was and he was
so consistent look there my mama right
there in church look my mama hold it up
mama hold it up yeah it is he hold it up
so we never made it in the sanctuary we
always in the satellite so growing up I
got to see an example of you know what
it was like to D up true professional in
the spotlight and never knew that I
would be at that level or that would be
an experience that I would have for
myself but those lessons really got
ingrained subliminally and so the people
who talk to me every once in while just
out of courtesy but it was never
anything you know about me first and
foremost so when I like you said going
to Davidson playing in the tournament
going to the Elite Eight
again a small mid major school going
that far all-american and all that type
of stuff like it was pretty much
overnight type of sensation and my
favorite I had back when Facebook was
with a sophomore in high school or my
sophomore in college came back after the
Elite Eight run and had my messenger
situation going on and literally I came
back to over like 2000 messages and my
computer crashed so like I guess what I
came back to a little dorm room at
Davidson I'm like I don't even know how
to handle this like what does that mean
like going and living my daily life now
you know doing interviews doing all this
other type of stuff and my foundation
was set because of what I got to see and
again that's something I told my dad all
the time like it could have gone all the
way the other way if he had had been a
different type of person or said a
different example for me and my brother
and my sister in terms of you know how
he handled himself how he carried
himself but I had to find what that
meant for me so I define you that that
patience and that graciousness and that
sense of again not taking myself too
seriously in the midst of success which
you have to make that commitment every
single day because if people are telling
you how great you are all the time and
telling you that you know you can do no
wrong and that you're perfect and all
that but you know you can buy into it if
you want to rest it's going to be a
recipe for disaster
if you don't really check yourself and
understand that one and I tried to
deflect as much as possible to exactly
you know my team because I knew that I
had power because of who I got to roll
with every single day on the court and
and that was that was big for me and
that's something that's a pretty
constant theme and everything that I've
been able to do in my career so let's
actually talk about that team that you I
just mentioned in 2009 you were drafted
by the Golden State Warriors in the
first round apparently that was not the
time to be a Warriors fan the wikipedia
refers to it as the wilderness years
wilderness years the wilderness years
where from I have never heard it we
believe to the wilderness years so there
was a period of 12 years in a row where
the Golden State didn't make the
playoffs yeah and that's what they refer
to with the world so lo and behold you
come in with your second Bowl prediction
and so you tweeted this I'm not gonna
read your Twitter promised to all the
Warriors fans we will figure this thing
out if it's the last thing we do we will
figure it out if I'm glad that's the
tweet they found
[Laughter]
so if this MBA thing doesn't work out
there's a lot of VC firms around here
looking for somebody existing sure I'm
trying to compete now true we'll talk
about that a little later so but back to
the team
what were the key cultural difference
between those early Warriors and the
Warriors of today how long do you have I
think we were I mean like you said it
was a it was a season of transition I
talked about the we believe team where
they had you know a set identity of kind
of just us there them or us against the
world and and that was you know what
works for them the nature of NBA took
over then you kind of go through a
period where you know from from
ownership all the way down he talked
about you know corporate culture and
just the environment you get to go to
work in a day it was all bad and so that
filter do everything that we did you
know and so from there you know that's
what I'm welcome to into as a
bright-eyed 21 year old rookie coming
from an 1800 you know student campus to
you know the west coast to the Bay Area
really just trying to play basketball
and learn and I think for me like I
didn't know it at the time but those
first three years was an opportunity for
me to kind of leave I didn't really have
a voice but I could lead by example
because I knew every day that I was
showing up to work and get better and
whether it was in front of people or my
teammates or management's or whatever
like I would try to be as consistent as
possible with that that would set me up
for when we figured out who I would our
identity was and got you know a solid
roster around that that was already in
place so that people could kind of just
fall in line and follow that that lead
and and and then great things would
happen so it's actually you know my
rookie year I played against you know
LeBron for the first time and
and he pulled me aside after we played
after the game was over and he knew he
had been in the league for about six
years so he kind of known a little bit
about trying to build an identity in the
league and he told me like literally all
you have to worry about right now is
kind of looking through a keyhole and
worrying about you know what are you
doing on a daily basis what habits are
you building that are going to set you
up for success down the road when things
line up because this industry is hard
this business like winning is hard I
learned that lesson every single night
but are you going to keep this time
productive because you're building the
right habits and you're understanding
exactly what type of player you want to
be so that when you know management
starts to get the roster in place and
the identity of ownership that for us
having that next year with Joe alaikum
and Peter Gulla Peter Guber buying the
team and really having a big perspective
about what it meant to be a warrior and
what it meant to represent the Bay Area
in the NBA that I would be ready to lead
at that point and so valuable obviously
advice from him too to kind of set it up
and then you know what six years later
or playing in the final so pretty crazy
pretty crazy journey coming from humble
beginnings you know winning 20 games a
year to to where we ended up yeah so you
mentioned LeBron earlier you missed you
mentioned your coach from Davidson as
two people who mentored you so I'm
curious if you were to flip that who are
the people that you've mentored or how
do you view mentorship from your your
lens that's a great question because I
feel like that's the best opportunity
for me that's ever ever developing in
terms of me realizing how powerful my
voice is in terms of you know how this
next generation you know sees me as a
basketball player you know the the you
call it I using this term but they call
it the the curry generation where kids
are trying to shoot from 40 feet you
know right right when they write when
they walk in the gym
and me trying to kind of level with them
like there's a process to this you have
to work our way in we're gonna work on
our mechanics and then eventually you
can get out to that to that range but in
terms of like just how the joy that I
try to bring and I think some of the the
wisdom that I have to you know these
eleven years that I've been playing that
I can pass on I'm an open books of you
know people reach out and they have I
love to kind of you know hopefully lead
them in the right direction I've had
some really great teammates and some
young guys that have been you know
through our through our our team that
have carried our culture to other you
know teams around the league and they
talk about how much it meant to play you
know during this era with with with me
and clay and Raymond and Andre and Sean
and Katie and and and those type of
opportunities so now it's I'm actually
taking you know a page out of Kobe's
book in terms of just you know he
through this tragedy so many different
people have kind of spoken about what he
meant to them and then just a little
like a simple text that he was saying
how much confidence that gave them and
you know I'm example that too one game
we were playing the Lakers and my rookie
year and I did a little spin move
situation headed off the glass and they
panned to him on the bench and he
mouthed off to one of his teammates it
next time like yo he's nice alright so
somebody sent me that clip right after
you don't know how much confidence that
gave me in that moment like I can I'm
the best player in the world now I just
for him saying that and almost
validating you know my skill level and
things like that so those moments are
just unbelievable to kind of be on the
other side of it now and I have an
opportunity to see you see guys you know
have similar type gains trade young like
that who's coming in with a whole nother
level of confidence because you got to
watch what I did you know coming up
through the through the ranks oh yeah
I'm available though but those hopefully
opportunities will keep coming I can
continue to give back to the game like
other guys gave me
you should lean into tray on you know
I'm from the Atlanta area so I'll do it
too much trying to stay on top you know
so you know let's go to 2011 in that
year the Warriors drafted klay Thompson
to earned the moniker the splash
brothers becoming the best duo to play
the game Wow you're always in a
spotlight looking around clay so I mean
clay sometimes will actively dodge the
spotlight so I'm curious when you take
two people who have such different
personalities what how would y'all build
that chemistry I think we had similar
similar beginnings in the league
mine was a more of a kind of I got
talked about lack of identity or dealing
with the lack of identity from an
organization and so much kind of
transition on the roster I really had to
focus on myself and I called the homo
beginnings of learning how it takes to
win for clay it was a position battle
like we had a guy on a Monta Ellis or
all the warrior fans know and clay was
his rookie year he was behind Monta and
had to fight to try to just get minutes
and so it's all about an appreciation
for just being on the floor plan and
then be able both come from NBA families
and there's a connection point with that
but understanding how we how we could
compete and practice to to make each
other better like we both love to shoot
the ball we should you know pretty well
and we always try to one-up each other
so there's a healthy competition when it
comes to that too and we're not afraid
to kind of lean into it and challenge
each other from time to time but you
know to your point around difference in
personalities I think we embrace it
because clay is the ultimate teammate
he's you know the most selfless guy
that's on our on our team that knows you
know whether he gets the shine or not or
whether people are talking about him or
not he knows how important he is to what
we do and to our winning culture and and
I try to do my best job every time I
have an opportunity to to let people
know like how important you know he is
to what we do and having each other's
back in that front you know it's it's a
mutual respect that will never ever go
away in terms of what we've been able to
Congress together and
it's weird talking about it now because
I know we still have you know a long
runway with this thing together so yeah
he's clay is one of the funniest dudes
you've ever met - so it's he's always a
great guy to be around he shows his
personality from time to time my
favorite you know I saw him drinking a
beer during an interview he's just he's
just in the moment all the time and I
love I love him as a teammate and it's
amazing and so you talked about him
being selfless but you yourself are also
selfless in 2000 after the 2016 you all
reached out to recruit Katie to join
your team it's not often you see someone
of your caliber who's willing to share
the spotlight with someone like Katie
right so I'm curious what what motivated
that humility in that moment to say you
know it's better for him to be on the
team and to share the spotlight rather
than you without him I mean it started
with him being interested Warren got it
you got to know that our friend age is
going cold knocking on Katie's door they
go nice weather out in the bay like you
know but once once you kind of get an
understanding that he wants to you know
he can see himself in a word uniform to
your to your question like I'd be an
idiot not not to you know follow kind of
you know my nature in terms of you know
understanding the value of and value of
the team but also not being afraid to be
around other talented people that can
push you because I some people might
think that's threatening and kind of
raining on my parade but a lot of it was
that I knew that we could together you
know push each other to ice that I don't
think either one of us imagined and
that's what we did every single day was
whether it was spoken about or not and
practice like I watched what he was
doing he watched what I was doing
and there's just a healthy just daily
motivation when it comes to that and you
know I wasn't afraid of it and I knew I
knew there would be some change
I personally going into it we all you
always have the strategy of like how
you're gonna deal with change and kind
of trying to get ahead of it so that you
prepared I thought that honestly the
dream on would have the biggest or the
heart had the hardest time dealing with
the the amount of talent that we had on
a team because we knew meekly and Katie
wouldn't get a bunch of shots and lo and
behold three months into the season it
was it was me that had the hardest time
kind of figuring it out because of just
the different roles that kind of formed
and and and how the game was being
played that you know I had to kind of
reset a little bit and understand like
where everybody wasn't a court in my
leadership style and being responsible
for you know how everybody was playing
that you know it was okay for everybody
to bring our ego our healthy egos and
being the best sell our best selves to
the to the floor every night and in that
it would work and so I think I
overcomplicated it at the beginning and
and that was that was something I had to
kind of work through and and eventually
to you know a lot of different tough
conversations and figuring it out you
know two championships and almost three
two rest is history so it was an amazing
journey amazing run that I'll never that
could be one of the greatest teams that
it was ever assembling yeah I remember
that for a long time
yeah it's eerily my favorite team ever
assembled so thank you all for going out
there and doing your thing so to switch
and talk about a different team we also
have your former Davidson teammate your
former Davidson roommate and the GS B's
very own
[Music]
so to launch SC 30 Inc and it so it
contains your brand endorsements
it contains your venture investing arm
it contains eat learn play and it also
contains unanimous media did I forget
anything it's pretty this late right
there it's a pretty good site that's
good so you know what exactly is the
mission of SC 38 it's to inspire I mean
bringing everything that I I'm about and
what I believe in to inspire and enhance
opportunities for the next generation so
I got to a point and he talked about you
know I was being friends from 2005 to
meeting in 2005 to now playing Davidson
together following his professional
career after you left Davidson to end up
here at the GSB and then you know after
that becoming business partners you know
we we try to stay patient and understand
that you know we were on a two totally
different journeys that eventually kind
of came together to make sense in terms
of his is a perspective on the
opportunities that I had off the court
that I might not have you know taken
advantage of otherwise and so when you
talk about those four verticals were
able to do so much I had the opportunity
to impact so many people inspire through
you know faith family through obviously
sports and through the ability to kind
of leverage what this is this game is
and the doors that it's open for me so a
lot of it's been a learning experience
and a huge learning curve in terms of
for seven years you know I had an agent
that kind of was it was amazing for that
part of my career but I got to a point
where I could take more ownership over
how I showed up in every
brant partnership and the opportunity to
reach the into Silicon Valley and
network and understand opportunities in
the venture space and me and my wife now
with the opportunity the Bay Area being
our home for the last 11 years when it's
where we raise our kids there's a huge
need and an opportunity to impact kids
in Oakland especially throughout and
throughout the Bay Area through those
three pillars of Veet learn and play and
then in the media space storytelling and
creating content that can impact you
know the world now and for years to come
trying to understand how I show up in
all those different verticals in a very
authentic way that I can own my voice
through all of that and and you know I
don't know you know this the impact now
but just in terms of you know thinking
long-term what people how people see me
on the basketball court there's way more
way more to it than that and so it's
been an exciting journey to be a part of
that and so to a crowd that you know
some people are considering starting a
company with their best friend or not
you have any advice
oh man I mean you just have to you just
have to communicate first and foremost I
think that was the the thing that was
most advantageous for us for two years
we had so many different conversations
about what it could look like and and
what that partnership would look like
and and how I think at a time you know
first two months it was tough because I
felt like for two years all we had was
business conversations and we forgot the
friendship part of it which was made us
who we are and then we kind of had to
kind of reset and say you know we're
doing amazing stuff if we lost that
personal you know part of it and that's
like that's a constant challenge and you
have to remind yourself without you know
crazy I mean decisions you have to make
on a daily basis all the things that
you're trying to manage and balance and
communication is everything and so I
come in Bryant for having that
perspective because he's not afraid to
challenge me on things where I'm
slipping up and and I hope I do the same
vice versa so you know that part of it
is is tough but it's the most rewarding
when you get to you know do amazing
things and enter amazing opportunities
with somebody as you know as it's very
similar mindset that you have you know
sweat equity with for years and years
and years you know what they're about
there's a confidence that comes with
that too so you take the good with the
with the decent with it yeah so thinking
back on a few things we've touched on
it's obvious that you don't let the
excellence of an organization define
your own excellence you went to Davison
underrated and left the household name
you went to a shaky Warriors team and
turn them into a dynasty to remember you
are ruining a game by redefining
excellence and everything you touch so I
want to let you know you know black man
a black man I appreciate everything you
do I appreciate all the positivity enjoy
what you bring into the world it's been
a pleasure chatting with you we're gonna
open it up to the audience for a few
questions
[Music]
[Applause]
I said thanks for coming I'm robbers and
first-gen ba so you just mentioned
you're putting this you know venture
we're doing with your friend so I'm just
wondering what's your you know overall
retirement plan who do you vision
yourself to be coming you know
23 years that I'm done around thank you
thank you I guess I'm at that point
where I start thinking about it a little
bit you know in terms of like where I'm
at my career I've always had a hard time
kind of articulating the big picture and
the strategy around what we're doing
with su-30 Inc and kind of what we
talked about those four verticals in the
media space of our foundation you learn
play which I truly believe will be a
game-changer in the Bay Area and
especially Oakland and changing kids
lives and that's something me and my
wife err extremely motivated and
dedicated to our brand partnerships and
in our venture investing so I think
establishing our processes and the team
that you know I'm trying to build now
that will hopefully set up successful
later just having a perspective and
around what that might look like you
know when the ball stops bouncing
obviously right now I have to balance
that perspective with continuing to be
the best basketball player that I can be
and keeping the main thing the main
thing for for me because that's what you
know keeps the car moving but I have had
the opportunity in this last year to
really again just adapt to the learnings
of what you know we have taken on and be
okay with saying you know we didn't get
that right the first time let's let's go
back to the drawing board
let's get you know the right getting the
right team in place and the right
process and I I'm only as good as the
people around me and so that's the
that's the best thing that we've been
able to try to figure out and I'm really
excited about where we're at right now
which continues to or allows me to have
the excitement about you know
reinvesting my time and the resources
behind everything that we're doing
that's my best answer to that because in
the next three or four years I want to
win like three more championships and
then play for like eight eight ten more
years and then you know I keep adding I
keep adding a year for my wife because
sounds just like the mess with her like
that but that's that's the perspective
right now continue be the best
basketball player I can be for as long
as I can be but in the meantime form the
best team around me that will help set
us up for success in the future in terms
of you know being truly game changers in
those four spaces I step my name is Mary
Grace Reeves I'm a fourth year in the
dual MD MBA program here at Stanford and
as a golfer I really appreciate your
show holy moly season two is coming soon
looking forward to you're always welcome
to join us here at the Stanford Golf
Course thank you for that anyway so my
question for you is now being on the
west coast what do you continue to take
from your Southern heritage and how does
that translate into your leadership
style on off the court with impact
investing in with the Animus media
that's a great question I get my joke
out the way like coming from the East
Coast my momma if I if I wasn't a yes
man no ma'am that type of thing just do
the the gracious isn't know my manners
she hit me upside my head so I've always
catches people off guard out here on the
west coast but beyond that I think just
a sense of a sense of appreciation for
the the place that I get to live I
really like the speed of life here the
opportunities the the thought leaders
and and game changes that right in this
area that I have you know access to and
you not being from here and kind of
understanding what that's like you know
in this last ten years has been
extremely rewarding I don't take that
for granted and
that the the people that I get to call
up and just have a conversation with her
he eventually hopefully go to go into
business with it just even get advice
from like that's that's that's amazing
to me just the power of intellect out
here just all you all you guys included
so that's that's pretty pretty special
to meet in this area and something that
gets me excited other than that that's
about it
so I think in terms of like again the
family aspect of what I bring in and
that kind of permeated itself through
you talk about unanimous and the content
that we create we want to create content
that the whole family can kind of get
behind and you want to make them laugh
make them cry make them smile all the
different emotions we bring that bond
together through it that's that's
important too yeah I think the last
student that actually a golfing question
ended up and getting Howard golf team
sponsors right yeah yeah that's right so
I did a screener for documentary called
Emmanuel last spring and part of that
was there's a guy that came up to the
front afterwards and he mentioned that
he was on the gull of the Howard Golf
Club team and he was trying to figure
out a way to start or bring Division one
golf back to Howard University obviously
being HBCU and so we had a conversation
found out a way to bring resources bring
some financial and kind of backing and
align all the forces to make that a
reality and you know what five six
months later it happened so crazy just
the the rooms that you're in and how
those type of ideas can kind of come and
then being able to execute it and make
you know make it into a reality it's
pretty dope so sponsoring the Howard the
the the return of Howard's the Division
one
team next fall is pretty pretty pretty
cool it's amazing I think we have time
for one more question from the crowd and
then we'll come back here
hi stuff thank you for being here
I was curious what the thought process
and conversation was around you and your
team's decision to not go to the White
House it personally meant a lot to me to
see I'm such prominent figures in the
public discourse make a stand like that
and I'm curious with that what that
process was like for you guys it was
kind of talking about that earlier and a
breakout group there is it's amazing the
conversations that I've been thrown into
and I say that in a positive way in
terms of how powerful your voice can be
and speaking for those that can't speak
for themselves and developing a point of
view that you're okay to stand behind no
matter if you're going to be praised for
it or her or be criticized for it and
that was probably the prime example of
of that happening in terms of how
basketball and the power of sports and
how it unifies people think better than
any other industry in this world can
lead to kind of standing against the way
that the presidential offices was being
represented and to be honest still is so
I think it was a powerful moment for our
whole team to kind of collectively come
together have that conversation amongst
ourselves of who was comfortable going
who was not obviously was on the side of
not going being put into a tweet but for
president Trump and and and dealing with
that backlash of of just that act that
at the end of the day I just didn't
agree with anything that he was saying
or what he stood for how he you know
talked about you know inclusivity and
the just the hatefulness I was coming
out of that office and so from there I
said I'm not going to the White House
and our team kind of came to that
collective decision we didn't go instead
we went to the National african-american
history or history museum and then DC
and and created our own experience that
was more true and authentic to what we
wanted to kind of understand and learn
about and share with the world and some
students from from where Katie's from
and Maryland came out and we got to go
tour the museum with them and it was an
amazing experience that was way better
than the alternative so just to your
point like athletes have an amazing
opportunity to speak and people want to
want to listen I just try to be the one
educated on what I'm talking about and
and to again okay with knowing I'm not
gonna please everybody with with what
you say but you got to stand for it
yeah so we had we had a breakout room
for you we also had a breakout room for
Aisha who is accomplished on our own we
have New York's Times best-selling book
the seasons life we have our own cooking
show Aisha is homemade and a cameo on
Hannah Montana that's good that's good
so we normally had to do my research man
so we normally in these with a lightning
round and I have one for you and so what
I'm gonna do is give you a series of
options
there's many two options in each one and
you tell me which one you pick you can't
you can't think about it too long all
right we're that's just about I'm
passing the ball just shoot the three
sounds good
all right so favorite acting moment
denzel washington and training day or
Viola Davis and how to get away with
murder
oh a training day okay favorite snack I
use just chicken parmesan or Sour Patch
Kids
that's fair favorite it's an unfair
question yeah to two totally different
categories I mean I'm married up and I'm
gonna make sure you know happy wife
happy life so I'm brought to you I
brought you a little gift
yeah that's my reward for answering the
question right so your favorite nickname
baby-faced assassin or splash bro
baby-faced assassin even though I'm
trying to run away from it obviously
alright so your favorite basketball role
model Steve Nash or Reggie Miller Steve
Nash Steve Nash which is crazy because
he's not one of our consultants for for
the team so I get to ask my idol
questions about how to run a
pick-and-roll and he gets the answer I'm
like right there and show me the way so
that's pretty pretty crazy that's pretty
well actually I think I read that he was
saying he wish he could play in the game
after you changed it unbelievable
compliment but I was also counter with I
play the way that I play because of what
he showed me so he's kind of done with
dumbing it down a little bit what he was
able to do in terms of reimagine or
reinventing creativity in a way that
inspired me to kind of own that for
myself so I appreciate his compliment
but yeah I learned it from him that
Phoenix Sun squad he was always crazy
last question this is this is a pretty
tough one there's actually three options
for this one favorite Chow Reilly okay
no kid will in on that one
[Applause]
[Music]